welcome to this next installation and
dr. Sadler's honest reviews this is a
series in which I review mostly recent
but occasionally classic works in the
intersections between philosophy
leadership and life so I look at
everything from practical philosophy to
self-help to as I mentioned leadership
and organizational behavior books the
one I have today to discuss is I guess
you could call it sort of an anthology
and new translation in a way it's
epictetus but it's this edition how to
be free and ancient guide to the stoic
life and it's the enchiridion and
selections from the discourses now
what's really the value add to this work
that I think might attract people to
buying it other than the nice cover and
the fact that it's part of what I think
is going to be a three part series is
that it's translated and it has a very
nice introduction by a a long great
scholarship of stoicism and of Epictetus
in particular it is part of a series I
reviewed the earlier installation in the
series how to dye which is selections
from Seneca this one is how to be free
and I imagine we can look forward to a
marcus aurelius work that has to do with
how to do something so I'm the whole I
think this is is quite good to have I'll
talk in a bit about the style the
structure about what I think are the
high points a few not quite criticisms
but at least things that I think that
the reader wants to know in order to
decide whether they want to purchase
this this work I will mention that the
price tag for this rather small volume
is sixteen ninety five us so that might
be a bit of a pain point or a bit of a
deal-breaker for some people but let me
tell you about the book itself and then
you can make your own decision
usually in this section on style and
structure in summary I begin with
talking about the author's style but I
think that it might be useful to
summarize first here what we've got
actually in this is work so this is the
enchiridion and some sections from
Epictetus is discourses all of those are
coming to us originally from Aryan who
was a student he was also a historian
and writer on his own and he studied
with-with-with Epictetus and then he
recorded what we think are more or less
verbatim teachings the enchiridion is
sort of the best hits list where he
assembled passages that he thought were
particularly apt and that's what you've
got in here it's all oriented around the
central theme of course of how to be
free so there's discussions of what real
freedom is as opposed to what people
consider to be freedom
the enchiridion it makes really good
sense to include that because freedom is
really one of the central themes within
that work and then the discourses
contain a lot of discussions of that as
well so that's really what this book is
about and it's ancient stoic teachings
by Epictetus you know we could talk
about epictetus his own style coming to
us through Aryan and then coming through
Long's translation Epictetus is a very
in-your-face sort of guy he doesn't pull
any punches
he doesn't can decode anything some
people find that a bit off-putting he
will call people slave of course that's
perfectly fine because he was himself a
slave he was born into slavery and was
later freed and lived in a place you
know at the time the ancient Roman
Empire where slavery was ubiquitous he's
perfectly fine with telling you how he
thinks things are and if you don't
accept it he's cool with that as well
he'll let you come back after you've you
know experienced a bit of stuff on your
own and maybe had some hard knocks
that's really there in the style and an
Aryan did a great job and caps
what we think is probably you know
verbatim
Epictetus his words and his way of
approaching people and long is somebody
who's been studying epictetus among
other Stoics for decades the translation
is very clear and i think that you can
say that the genuine Epictetus has not
been masked and is coming through so
that's a bit about the style long
himself is you know worth mentioning
because there's a long introduction that
he provides that i think it's quite good
long as a particularly clear writer he's
he's keen to make sure that whenever he
uses a term from the ancient greek he
likes to explain it which i think is a
great feature of his work and i think is
part of why he's become such a major
scholar not only for academics but also
for the broader public when it comes to
stoicism so that's enough about style
let's talk about what is actually in
this book so it begins with an
introduction by by anthony long and it's
it's quite good there's there's quite a
few things in the introduction it's it's
about looks like about fifty odd pages
short pages of course but he's giving
you a lot of really helpful background
information just in case you don't
already have that so he texts about you
know here's sections on stoicism and
freedom Epictetus as a stoic teacher
what living in harmony with nature where
in accordance with nature means and he
directs you to the texts and he also
explains these things along the way then
you'd have the enchiridion and one of
the features of this work that I will
point out as you can see that you have
the English on one side and the Greek on
the other side so it's a facing pages
edition as is the earlier volume in this
series on Seneca that's kind of good in
some ways problematic and in some other
ways as I'll talk about
it's nice because if you do want to go
directly to the Greek if you can read it
you can do that by by just looking at
the side-by-side comparisons so he has
the enchiridion and that occupies really
about oh I would say more than yeah a
little bit more than half of the the
work itself so you can see here sort of
the breakdown and then there's nine
extended passages from Epictetus
discourses that have to do with freedom
what the conditions for freedom are how
we make ourselves free how we enslave
ourselves and all of this is is
applicable to our everyday lives whether
we're in ancient Rome or whether we're
in 21st century wherever we happen to be
in the world long is a very accessible
writer as I've pointed out he's also
very scholarly and he's even and I find
this you know enjoyable he's even quite
witty at points as well so that's style
summary and structure of the work
let
about the central ideas that you're
gonna find in this work one of which of
course is is freedom I mean the book is
called how to be free and the Stoics
actually talked quite a lot about
freedom Epictetus perhaps more than
anybody else I would say given the works
that we do have of them it's important
to remember that of course we've lost
more than 90% of the stoic literature
that was available in antiquity and
that's sort of a ballpark gasps epic
Tina's talks a lot about the nature of
genuine freedom how people get mixed up
about what freedom consists in what it
is that we do that impedes our freedom
how we misuse our freedom to make
ourselves less free what slavery
consists in and what it is that we can
do to be free how we can be free what
sort of techniques or mindsets do we do
we need to have and for the Stoics being
free in the full sense would mean only
being concerned with the things that
really are within our control or that
you know we can have some influence over
in part because they are in our control
like we can't control how other people
react but we certainly can control
whether we create openings for good
relationships we can't control whether
something is going to be successful or
not but we control whether we try and
Epictetus will say over and over again
if you want to be free you need to focus
on the things that are actually within
the sphere of your control so you know
parsing that out is is quite important
he also says that when we allow
ourselves to be you know attracted to or
desire or averse to things that somebody
else has control over we in effect make
ourselves slaves of that person and make
that person our master and we could say
similar things about not just people but
processes and things you know if
drinking it becomes the center of your
life you you are out of control and
something else is controlling you if the
desire for status and prestige is what's
driving you man that's going to be a
hard life that's what Epictetus
and it's a less free life so that's one
key theme another thing that I'll say
goes on in the work quite a lot is a
clarification of key ideas and terms and
that's you know
Epictetus does that to some degree but
long is really doing that especially in
the introduction and I should mention
that there's also a nice you know end
part with a glossary right where he goes
over things for example harmony of the
universe harmonies Greek symphonia
invokes the Stoics favorite musical
model for a unitary structure the unity
of opposites is an idea that looks back
to the early Greek philosophers
Pythagoras and Heraclitus right so long
is giving you some background
information that's quite helpful he's
explaining the key ideas and terms of
this work another thing that I would say
runs through the selections that long
hands here and the enchiridion is the
relationship of freedom to all these
other concepts that play a major role in
stoic philosophy including desire and
choice and nature but one of the key
ideas that you find
Epictetus stressing more than the other
Stoics is what we translate as will you
know long translates that is will
sometimes there can be some problems
with that oftentimes it's translated
Faculty of choice or you know by other
locations as well it's connected to what
the Stoics called the ruling principle
or the rational principle moral purpose
is another translation you might think
of it as the Nexus of our choices and
commitments and prioritizations which
include ourselves within it as well as
external things and this is really
absolutely central for epictetus and and
freedom is going to be really when it
comes down to it the freedom of the
prior ASIS or of the will which is one
reason why other authors who long is
very conversant with have
Epictetus as almost getting to what
later thinkers are actually gonna call
the will being almost like one step away
from it
one other theme I would say that that
runs through this is the need to take
our cues for what constitutes genuine
freedom and its opposite slavery not
from the external world not from the
culture not from social institutions but
from something deeper within something
that's central to us as human beings and
stoic philosophy would be the way to
illuminate that so those are some key
ideas that you're going to see handled
in this work
I have quite a few good things to say
about this book and really that's not
surprising given the fact that you know
it's long who's translating it and
providing the introduction it's pretty
rare as a matter of fact I can't think
of a single thing by long where I would
even if I disagree with it
at points say this is not excellent
stuff he's a major major scholar in
stoic studies those of us who has
academics or as more popular writers
work in the field of stoicism Oh him an
incredible debt for doing a lot of
academic groundwork and popularizing of
stoicism so this is you know pretty much
along the same lines as other things
he's got excellent translations I can't
find any fault with them he actually has
a long discussion here about why he
translated the way he did in which text
he was also looking to the introduction
I think is really helpful as a matter of
fact I may in fact use that for some
students down the line there's also as I
put it out this nice glossary in the
back that that covers a lot of concepts
I think that could be very very useful
for people who are encountering
Epictetus or stoicism for the first time
there are key subject headings for each
of the discourses I like that idea
because it helps you figure out what
you're getting into and you know long is
quite good about connecting this
material to the broader field of
standards stoic literature so you know
you're not going to read this and then
not find it connecting up with
everything else or get lost it's it's
great introduction to Epictetus --is
thought and I think that long himself
gives a really solid sense of epictetus
as teachings and ideas again not just in
the introduction but also in the way
that he goes about translating so these
are
all things that I consider to be good
features of the work
I can't say that I have any actual
criticisms per se of this book there are
a few things that I I guess I would say
at best I find them problematic but this
this may be more about me and less about
some some readers some people may
actually find these to be good points
you know I think that this entire series
the decision to make the facing pages
you know with the Greek or Latin on one
side and the English on the other I'm
not really that happy about that
decision because this could be a shorter
smaller book that's easier to just carry
around in your pocket if they did that
and I don't think that most of the
readers who this is supposed to reach
really need the the Greek text on the
the opposite page it looks cool but how
many people read classical Greek I mean
I do and it's nice for that but if I
want to read
Epictetus I'm just gonna get my Loeb
edition down from the shelf and go
through that because it's you know it's
it's got all of epictetus and stuff in
it rather than just these selections I
think that the people who are likely to
be interested in having selections are
probably less interested in the facing
text and that you know that's part of
what led to the high price for this the
1695 for a pretty small selection of
Epictetus you know the attraction of
having Long's more contemporary
translation rather than the old father
that's in the lobe okay that that's kind
of good but you can get the lobe full
epictetus for about forty dollars so you
know if you're really into having the
facing pages with the Greek and the
English you know that might be the way
to go as well the other thing that I'll
say and again I'm not actually
complaining or criticizing long in this
because I don't envy the position that
he was in with somebody like Epictetus
boy it's tough to
to figure out what you would put into
this this little selection book because
there's so many other discussions of
freedom and slavery that could have made
their way in here but then it would have
been a much larger book and I'm sure
that his commission was to you know just
pick the most essential passages and I
think he did a good job with that
so again not not complaining but I just
want to say that there are there's more
to Epictetus on freedom and slavery then
you're gonna find in this this work
so to sum up is this worth getting well
if you want a selection of Epictetus
passages on freedom and slavery
translated by a really great
well-informed highly regarded stoic
scholar and you want the the Greek and
the English on facing pages then maybe
you want to buy this volume and if
you've already got the Seneca on how to
die maybe this is the companion piece
that you put next to it if you you know
want to get your epic Tunis from other
sources it's very easy to do so and you
don't necessarily need to have this
volume I think that you know it's got
some nice features to it you know and
I'm you know a big fan of a long anyway
so I'm happy that they sent this to me
but I don't know that this is a book
that I myself would have purchased on my
own so it's really up to you as the
reader you have to weigh this and think
about do I do I want to have this
particular Edition there are some points
recommending it but you know it's it's
not absolutely essential to have this
particular set of selection so that
would be you know your own judgment call
you